L
WEAPONIZATION OF THE FBI
TONIGHT.
>>> FIRST HOUSE SPEAKER PELOSI
RECEIVING AN INTERESTING
GREETING IN NEW YORK CITY AS SHE
MAKES A SURPRISE APPEARANCE AT A
MUSIC FESTIVAL.
>> NANCY PELOSI.
>> AS YOU CAN SEE THERE, THERE
WERE SOME BOOS.
AN INTERESTING WELCOME IN
LIBERAL NEW YORK CITY.
PELOSI REALLY GEARING UP FOR THE
MIDTERMS.
SHE'S ONE OF THE FIRST GUESTS ON
THE NEW SHOW ON HULU POWER TRIP.
SHE SHOWED OFF HER FITNESS WITH
A BRISK WALK, WITH GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS TALKING ABOUT HOW
REPUBLICANS WILL DESTROY
DEMOCRACY IF THE POWER GOES TO
THE G.O.P. IN NOVEMBER.
>> MIDTERM, OUR DEMOCRACY AS YOU
SEE BECAUSE THEY ARE NULLIFYING
ELECTIONS, AND THAT'S PART OF
THEIR AGENDA.
THE FATE OF THE PLANET, WHICH
THEY ARE IN DENIAL.
THEY'RE STILL ANTISCIENCE AND
ANTIGOVERNANCE TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
>> A PINNACLE OF FITNESS THERE.
IN THE MEANTIME, REPUBLICAN
LEADERS MAKING THE ROUNDS ON
SUNDAY SHOWS TOUTING THEIR NEW
PLAN FOR CHANGE.
HERE'S CONGRESSWOMAN AND G.O.P.
CONFERENCE CHAIR EARLIER TODAY
ON FOX NEWS SUNDAY.
>> NOT ONLY ARE WE GOING TO EARN
BACK THE HOUSE, BUT WE'RE GOING
TO EARN BACK THE SENATE AS WELL.
AND WE WILL SEND EVERY BIT OF
LEGISLATION THAT WE PROMISED TO
THE PRESIDENT'S DESK, AND IT IS
UP TO BIDEN WHETHER HE WORKS
WITH US OR WHETHER HE WILL PLAY
POLITICS AND VETO THESE
IMPORTANT BILLS TO REIN IN
INFLATION, TO SUPPORT IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN MAKE SURE WE HAVE
A SAFE COUNTRY, AND TO SECURE
THE BORDER WHICH IS IN FREE FALL
UNDER BIDEN'S AMNESTY POLICIES.
>> REGISTERED DEMOCRATS ARE FED
UP WITH WHAT THEY CALL THE
RADICAL LEFT AND SWITCHING
PARTIES.
ONE SWITCH TO REPUBLICAN TELLING
THE NEW YORK POST, QUOTE, THE
REASON I REGISTERED AS A
REPUBLICAN HAS MORE TO DO WITH
THE DEMOCRATS THAN IT DOES WITH
THE REPUBLICANS.
I STILL CONSIDER MYSELF LIBERAL
IN A LOT OF WAYS, BUT I'M NO
LONGER REGISTERED DEMOCRAT.
THEY'VE JUST REALLY GONE OFF THE
RAILS THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT
PERSONALLY.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A POLL HERE
THAT JUST SHOWS WHERE THE G.O.P.
IS ON THE ISSUES.
AND THEY ARE REALLY LEADING.
WE CAN SHOW THE G.O.P.'S PLUS
FIVE ON THE GENERIC BALLOT AMONG
LIKELY VOTERS, PLUS 21 IN SWING
DISTRICTS.
IF YOU GO BACK TO THE QUOTE,
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING IT IS NOT
ABOUT THE REPUBLICANS POSITION,
NOT THIS NEW PROMISE TO AMERICA,
COMMITMENT TO AMERICA, MAYBE ALL
OF THAT DOESN'T MATTER, MAYBE
THEY NEED TO CONTINUE TO POINT
OUT THAT LIBERAL ARE KIND OF
RADICAL.
-- LIBERALS ARE KIND OF RADICAL.
>> LOOK AROUND, HOW IS YOUR
FAMILY AND BANK ACCOUNT DOING?
SPEAKER PELOSI CAN HUFF AND PUFF
ON HER WALK WITH STEPHANOPOULOS
AND TALK ABOUT HOW DEMOCRACY
COULD DIE AND THE FATE OF THE
PLANET IS AT STAKE IN A MIDTERM
ELECTION, VERY OVER THE TOP I
THINK RHETORIC FROM HER, AND
MOST VOTERS LOOK AT THAT AND SAY
IT IS BIT MUCH.
WE PUT THE GRAPHIC UP.
THIS IS A BRAND NEW WASHINGTON
POST ABC NEWS POLL OUT TODAY FOR
REPUBLICANS TO BE UP 5 ON
GENERIC BALLOT AMONG LIKELY
VOTERS IS A BIG DEAL, IN THE
SWING DISTRICTS UP 21 POINTS.
ON THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE THE
ECONOMY, THE REPUBLICANS ARE UP
16 POINTS, UP 14 ON CRIME.
THESE ARE THE BREAD AND BUTTER
LAW AND ORDER ISSUES THAT PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT THE MOST.
AND I THINK A LOT OF THE NOISE
THAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM THE
DEMOCRATS IS SORT OF THEIR
ADMISSION THAT THEY KNOW THEY
ARE IN SOME TROUBLE SO THEY ARE
THROWING THESE DISTRACTIONS TO
TRY TO GET PEOPLE SCARED AND
MOTIVATE THEIR FOLKS.
IT COMES DOWN TO INFLATION,
ECONOMY, REPUBLICANS YOU CAN SEE
THE NUMBERS ON THE SCREEN, AND
THEY ARE STRIKING.
>> THE DEMOCRATS MESSAGE
IT
NOW IS MAGA EXTREMISM, THE FIRST
POINT THEY HAVE.
THE NEXT POINT THEY HAVE IS THAT
BASICALLY IS THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
IS THE ROOT TO ALL EVIL.
THAT'S THE MOST POLICY BASED
POINT THEY HAVE.
THEN FROM THERE THEY ARE TRYING
TO TELL YOU THAT WHAT YOU THINK
IS HAPPENING ISN'T ACTUALLY
HAPPENING.
INFLATION ISN'T UP THAT MUCH.
WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE BORDER,
THEY ARE ONLY GOING TO ADDRESS
THE BORDER IF THEY ADDRESS WHAT
GOVERNORS ABBOTT AND DESANTIS
HAVE DONE BY MOVING MIGRANTS
FROM TEXAS AND FLORIDA.
IT SEEMS THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
ISSUE PLATFORM TO SELL IN THE
MIDTERMS
>> THEY ARE IN A SPOT.
WHEN YOU SHOWED THAT QUOTE FROM
THAT VOTER WHO SWITCHED OVER,
WHO SAID THEY STILL CONSIDER
THEMSELVES QUITE LIBERAL,
HOWEVER THEY FELT LIKE THEY WERE
NOW MORE OF A REPUBLICAN, I CAN
TELL YOU FROM TALKING TO VOTERS
OUT THERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
COUNTRY, IN THE SOUTHERN PART OF
THE COUNTRY, WHEN I SAY SOUTH, I
DON'T LIKE YOUR SOUTH, I MEAN
TEXAS AND SOUTHERN ARIZONA,
THERE ARE SO MANY VOTERS OUT
THERE WHO FEEL LIKE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS GONE TO THE
LEFT TO SUCH AN EXTREME, AND
THESE ARE LIFELONG DEMOCRATS WHO
NOW SAY THEY ARE CHANGING.
IT'S CASE IN POINT, LATINO
VOTERS, THEY ARE CONSTANTLY
TELLING US OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THAT THINGS HAVE CHANGED SO
MUCH, BUT THEY HAVEN'T.
THE PARTY HAS CHANGED.
AND SO I THINK THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR REPUBLICANS
RIGHT NOW FROM A STRATEGIC
STANDPOINT IS TO KEEP THE FOCUS
AND THE COLLECTIVE DISCIPLINE ON
THE ECONOMY AND ON CRIME, AND IF
THEY CAN DO THAT, THEN THEY HAVE
A PATH.
>> I THINK MCCARTHY WOULD AGREE
WITH YOU.
THAT'S WHY THEY ROLLED OUT THIS
COMMITMENT THE WAY THEY DID.
I THINK, LAURA, IT IS FUNNY.
PELOSI BEING BOOED IN NEW YORK
CITY, WE'RE IN NEW YORK CITY.
>> WOW.
>> THESE PEOPLE CARE ABOUT THE
CRAZY THINGS SHE PUSHES.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY FOR WHERE
DEMOCRAT LEADERSHIP IS?
>> WELL, I CAN'T THINK OF A
BIGGER BUZZ KILL AT A CONCERT
THAN INVITING NANCY PELOSI ON
STAGE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO HAD THAT GRAND
IDEA, BUT OBVIOUSLY, I DON'T
THINK IT WORKED OUT QUITE LIKE
THEY SHE EXPECTED IT TO.
BUT THAT WAS THE FIRST THING I
THOUGHT WHENEVER I HEARD THIS IS
THIS IS LIBERAL NEW YORK CITY.
THESE ARE HER PEOPLE, AND THE
FACT THAT NANCY PELOSI DID NOT
WALK OUT AND IT WAS FULL
APPLAUSE AND PEOPLE ARE JUST
GOING CRAZY FOR HER IN A
POSITIVE WAY, MAYBE IT TELLS YOU
THAT THE YOUNGER GENERATION
PERHAPS, I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE
THEY'RE REALIZING ALL OF THIS
SPENDING OUT OF CONTROL ONE DAY
IS GOING TO FALL IN THEIR LAP.
MAYBE THEY JUST DIDN'T WANT
THEIR CONCERT RUINED BY NANCY
PELOSI, BUT I THINK THAT IT IS A
SIGN THAT PERHAPS PEOPLE ARE
WAKING UP AROUND THE COUNTRY.
PERHAPS PEOPLE ARE GETTING THE
BIGGER PICTURE.
WE HAVE ALL COMMENTED ON THE
DEMOCRAT TURN REPUBLICAN.
ALICIA WHAT YOU SAID I THINK IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
I HAVE HEARD IT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN TO MANY PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, I HAVEN'T LEFT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY LEFT ME.
I THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE FEELING
LIKE THAT ACROSS THE BOARD, AND
GUY, LIKE YOU SAID, IF YOUR LIFE
ISN'T AS ROSY, SUNSHINE,
LOLLIPOPS AND RAINBOWS AS THE
DEMOCRATS ARE PAINTING IT,
PERHAPS YOU MIGHT WANT TO TRY
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
>> ON THAT TOPIC, GUY, I WILL
LET YOU RESPOND TO THIS, THIS IS
ANOTHER DEMOCRATIC VOTER, THIS
IS ANOTHER QUOTE, LOOKING BACK
AT THE DEMOCRAT PARTY IN THE 80s
AND 90s, I THINK I WOULD BE A
DEMOCRAT.
I TAKE SOME IDEAS FROM THE LEFT.
SOME IDEAS FROM THE RIGHT.
BUT I DON'T FEEL I IDENTIFY WITH
ANY TRIBE.
THAT LAST QUOTE TALKED ABOUT HOW
THEY IDENTIFIED AS A LIBERAL BUT
NOT A DEMOCRAT.
HOW FAR HAS THIS PARTY GONE FROM
WHAT WOULD BE ITS BASE?
>> I THINK THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO FEEL SORT OF
POLITICALLY HOMELESS IN THIS
VERY TRIBAL AREA.
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT TRADITIONALLY
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
LEFT-LEANING, MAYBE SOCIALLY
LIBERAL ON SOME THINGS, BUT THEN
THEY LOOK AROUND AT THEIR TRIBE,
PERHAPS, AND THEY SEE SOME OF
THE REALLY OUT OF CONTROL SORT
OF WOKE ENFORCEMENT, RIGHT,
WHERE YOU MUST SAY EVERYTHING
EXACTLY CORRECTLY, OR IT'S A
HATE CRIME OR WHATEVER.
>> YEAH.
>> AND THEY ARE NOT INTO THAT.
SO I THINK SOME OF THAT IS
DRIVING PEOPLE AWAY FROM THAT
COALITION, AND QUICKLY, LAURA, I
THINK WITH PELOSI GETTING BOOED,
MY TAKE IS A LITTLE MORE
CYNICAL.
MOST PEOPLE WHO BOOED PROBABLY
WANTED THE MUSIC TO RESUME, NOT
A POLITICAL SPEECH.
I ALSO THINK IN NEW YORK CITY,
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE HAVE
PROTESTED SCHUMER AT HIS HOUSE
IN BROOKLYN BECAUSE THEY AREN'T
RADICAL ENOUGH.
I THINK SOME OF THE BOOS WOULD
HAVE BEEN THE LEFT WING, SHE'S A
CORPORATE MODERATE DEMOCRAT.
>> THAT'S FRIGHTENING.
>> THAT MIGHT DRIVE A FEW MORE
PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR COALITION IF
THEY GET FURTHER DRAGGED TOWARDS
THE SQUAD.
>> 2016, ALICIA, PRESIDENT TRUMP
CANDIDATE TRUMP AT THE TIME
WHICH WAS AMERICA FIRST, BRING
JOBS BACK TO AMERICA, SECURE THE
BORDER, NOT NECESSARILY SPECIFIC
TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, MORE SO
KITCHEN TABLE IDEAS THAT
PEOPLE -- HEY, I WOULD LOVE FOR
MY JOB TO COME BACK.
I DON'T WANT MY REPLACEMENT TO
TRAIN ME TO SEND MY JOB
OVERSEAS.
IF THE DEMOCRATS HAVE ANY
VERSION OF THAT, IT IS WOKE,
IDENTITY, AND CLIMATE.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE THAT'S GOING
TO RESONATE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS WHOLE BLOCK.
>> YOU ALSO HAVE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF PARENTS WHO ARE SO
UPSET ABOUT WHAT THEY SAW DURING
THE COVID LOCKDOWNS AND WHAT
THEY ARE STILL CONTINUING TO SEE
WITH REGARD TO EDUCATION.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
YESTERDAY.
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
FOR PEOPLE OUT THERE, BECAUSE
IT'S SO TROUBLING THAT THE
PARENTS OUT THERE ARE FEELING
LIKE THEY'RE NOT IN CONTROL
ANYMORE, AND IT'S THEIR OWN
KIDS' EDUCATION.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LAURA, LAST WORD, I MEAN, KIDS
KIND OF ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IN OUR LIVES WHEN WE'RE
PARENTS AREN'T THEY?
>> END ALL, BE ALL, OUR MOST
IMPORTANT THING AS A PARENT.
IT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
FOR THE FUTURE OF OUR COUNTRY,
OUR NEXT GENERATION.
ALICIA, YOU ARE RIGHT, PARENTS
DON'T LIKE BEING TOLD THEY ARE
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS FOR GOING TO
A SCHOOL BOARD MEETING AND
VOICING THEIR OPINION.
OBVIOUSLY THE GOAL OF THAT WAS
TO GET EVERYBODY TO SIT DOWN AND
SHUT UP AND DON'T STEP OUT OF
LINE.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE
THEIR VOICES HEARD ON NOVEMBER
8TH.
>> A QUICK CAUTIONARY NOTE, IT
IS NOT LIKE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY'S NUMBERS ARE GLITTERING
RIGHT NOW.
PEOPLE AREN'T HAPPY WITH THE
DE